[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by ian harding aka
eddie and long slow exhale which is
coming to spectrum april 4th ian how you
doing today man good how are you steve
good so uh are you very selective about
what parts you take and what was
specific about this role that kind of
reeled you in i you know i
i always try and do if if you can you
know sometimes as an actor uh
you know you you take what you get and
and uh but i was so lucky with this that
like this was
this was something that i
was drawn to as well as
intimidated by you know um where i
wasn't quite sure where he stood on
certain
things and and i knew that it was a
sort of a complex issue and i think that
you know the the show handles it with
with you know a very sort of sticky and
taboo subject but a pertinent one and
one that needs to be spoken about but it
handles it with grace and manages to
make compelling television as well as
you know something that is entertaining
and sexy at the same time um and so that
like you know that i really loved and
and i also knew that i'd be working with
with rose and josh and and that was
something that i wanted to do so it was
kind of in many ways it was pretty much
your dream job
yeah and you do great with it and it's
cool because the character of eddie he's
very mysterious so
i'm wondering with that when you're
approaching that part do you have to
know all these secrets in his head that
we don't know his audience yet to pull
that off or do you can you kind of you
know fake it a bit yeah you know
it's tough i mean sometimes uh i would i
would love to say that i'm just such a
brilliant actor that i i you know i've
got like this depth and some you know
there are times where i've watched
things in the past like with my parents
or something like wow like what in that
moment like there's something mysterious
like what are you doing and i was like
honestly i'm trying to remember my lines
you know so the thing like i look off
into the distance and it's like oh like
something's there and in fact i'm like
oh [ __ ] was it the oh right yeah you
know so so no but i think i think with
with with eddie i wanted to play him
there could be no
um
seediness or like nothing slimy or slick
he had to be somebody that i think the
audience like had to buy that they like
you almost feel for him and like to the
point where you're like wait but how is
this happening to him he's such a nice
guy you know yeah yeah
and so but you know and as the story
unfolds like you start to see like how
his actions
have are affecting him and like and how
he got into the situation and so in many
ways like as an actor i had to play him
as his own sort of victim which is you
know
pam was really great in that we would
have conversations where
whenever as as an actor you have to kind
of defend your character you have to
take their side
and so there were times where especially
with this character i really learned how
to do that where i'm sticking up for a
guy
who's who's he's got a lot to answer to
you know he's got a lot to sort out and
so i'd be having these conversations
like defending myself and i'm so happy
that nobody was standing around with a
microphone because
you know you know i i would say things
where i'm like well how do you know that
she didn't you know and you're right
can't say that you know yeah
but you have to defend this person so it
was
both you know painful cathartic and and
you know uh all of those things at once
that that's a great answer and it's so
interesting how like deep you look into
that i love you talking about defending
a character like this which is
so true and i i wonder too like for the
physicality of the part or just the
sport layer of this part are you
watching like footage of assistant
coaches in real life is there anyone
that particularly inspired you like is
that something in your prep that you
actually do yeah well i went and met a
real life sort of assistant coach for
georgia tech a woman named blanche
albertson and she was so helpful and and
um but i really just wanted to know like
all right so so what is like what does
game day look like what does like your
daily practice schedule look like how
often are you involved like with these
you know uh players like day to day
life and you know especially there's
something with eddie that that
he
he was there's like a lack of awareness
and and i was and from the outside i was
like how could he not be aware that some
of this might be seen as slightly
inappropriate and then i actually
watched footage of of people of like
coaches where like you know some player
uh will sink like the game-winning shot
she'll run off the court and jump into
the like you know into people's arms and
like right there's definitely like
a familial almost an almost like
familial intimacy there
where the line is very blurry
and you know he's a young coach he's a
handsome coach and which i realize i
just called myself handsome but like you
know like
what a douche
but like you can see how things
get confused and so
that that that was really helpful to
talk to her and sort of get a feel for
what a team actually
like what that that environment is like
so you got all these things in your mind
though when you're doing this part so my
question to you though is when you're on
set and you're i'm pretty sure of
basketball fan in real life if i
remember you tweeted about watching a
lakers game and
whatever so is it hard to focus like do
you want to kind of just go shoot a ball
on set like on court like is that a
tough
gig distraction wise actually honestly
the biggest distraction that i had on
set was rose rollins because she because
we had worked together years ago on this
thing and and uh and she was always like
so much fun and i remember thinking back
then i was like man it'd be great to
work with her again but you know that
rarely happens because you know there's
so many actors so many projects et
cetera and and lo and behold this like
fell in my lap and and i was like oh my
god i was wrong you know and so we have
like a nice reporter we make each other
laugh and like it was
problematic at times because it'd be
like a really like a climactic scene
like we got to be in it it's like there
are snot and tears and like all this
other stuff and and i realized one day
like
her chair was like away from mine and it
was very clear that she had purposely
separated herself
my dad from
something to her and and that was wrong
and she was like no you just i cannot be
this happy around yeah
like yeah i need to go do that scene you
know yeah so so that was honestly the
biggest distraction was from rose
rollins so yeah it's like you guys like
each other too much it's that's great
and
the other thing too you know speaking of
you're talking about just excited about
taking on this part but if you look at
like your career directory it's like you
know pretty little liars is this
insanely successful show that you're in
right and you're such a big part of that
show was there like for you is there a
downside to that though like do you feel
like a pressure that you live you have
to live up to that kind of success of a
show again like you crave that now is
that like oh uh you know i uh i don't i
i i'm really good at um
you know actually especially from an
actor's perspective i feel like i could
talk about this for an hour and a half
on just this question but like i guess
bullet points is you know that as an
actor what you want to do is interesting
stories and and and you know be take on
interesting roles um
the fame side of it has never really
appealed to me i enjoy like job security
and you know occasionally getting like a
table at a restaurant that i wouldn't
have otherwise gotten unless the hostess
had
recognized me
but yeah um i i want the most
i want a lot of success for this show so
that the people that i know of like the
blood sweat and tears that have gone
into it that that's recognized and that
you know we get like a season two and i
can hang out with these people again you
know and
um but the the whole fame side of things
you know is is can be a lot so i'm you
know i don't live in l.a or
anymore you know and and that was really
helpful um
and so it's i'm great i'm great with
being
i almost kind of kind of find it a
little funny because people will be like
oh my god wait
are you and i kind of like well yeah and
they're like oh my god i love doing
vampire diaries and i was like
oh that's no that's not me no no wait
who are you and then you go through that
whole thing and so yeah yeah so yeah i i
hope the best for this show and i want
it to be i want it to explode and be a
huge thing sure um sure i mean look you
have an effect on people like someone i
saw on twitter had your face tattooed on
them do you think about that like does
that oh yeah even process that how many
people can say that
that's you know it's it's a crazy thing
i think ultimately as long as you can
kind of use it for good
and uh as much good as you can and then
know that that is not
you
people what people are obsessed with is
a character and that character is
writing or is the is the writing in the
direction of all these people involved
and is the hair and makeup
certainly the hair and makeup for me
and so
and so it's all of that and that's what
people
really fall for and then you know and
then
it's great when somebody like recognizes
you on the street and they're like
oh we
are you a person yeah
like yeah i think i'm
sweaty and tired and i got bags under my
eyes and it's great you know that's
amazing so
my last question for you before you go
what's the ultimate bird you're trying
to lay eyes on one day what's the white
race
um you know actually uh i moved to the
east coast and i don't think i'm gonna
actually get up to see it but there's um
um there's something there was a stellar
sea eagle spotted in maine
and that's it's it's gigantic bird it
makes the bald eagle look like a pigeon
um and not to crap on pigeons but
because they crap on everything else uh
but yeah i would love to go see that but
i don't think i'm gonna get a get a
chance to see it but uh great
yeah no look i i think you will one day
and your next book's gonna be on it i
can't wait
thank you for joining me today everybody
check out ian harding just crush it in
long slow excel which is on spectrum on
april 4th and i hope to talk to you
future one day thanks so much thank you
yeah thank you for having me